welcome to this video five-minute game
on the SEC and this will get this will
be tricky decided to scratch the warm-up
games or at least one or two I usually
play but in view of the football world
cup I thought that well let's skip the
warm-up and they do those penalty
shootouts they also cannot warm-up so
play and make it count okay let's see we
have a French defense opponent is going
awesome somewhat strange setup with
nights here yeah we go to an IQ p
position whereas night is somewhat um
yeah uncomely placed on e2 now maybe can
go to see three or something hmm okay um
I'm not sure here should I should I play
Knight to g5 just block it you know
maybe not quite clear unlike be four
also was a move but ok that was a boss
was fine what I don't have is a clear
idea what you do with my light squared
Bishop maybe maybe I can go Bishop to d7
rook datsheffy eight this type of setup
it's not so easy to feel and shatter it
because the rukon c1 always puts
pressure on the night so I'm scratching
the idea to fianchetto it that can take
d for now not really clear what what has
against that so I'm taking it
the central pawn is nothing to be
ignored okay I can take you three why
not Knight f6 I take with the Queen so
it's giving up yet another pawn why not
clear if I now take III teenage one now
I can certainly do that I don't really
think it has a drawback I'm only
wondering if it is worth it to take it
going i can also just go to e5 yeah
c'mon v5 is a monster square for the
Queen it just in the middle of the board
cannot be attacked somehow and if i take
here King King back okay rook the eighth
queen age five some weird stuff maybe
maybe I could have just taken but this
really seems easier when ice walking
right into f5 does you really have
anything great against that I don't
cannot really imagine what it might be
my queen on if I this is also protected
so after Queen h5 there's no pin on the
fifth-ranked I can just take the night I
don't see a problem okay if I take it
now yeah my take with the bishop and
threaten checkmate but it's really just
just this one threat i can't play g 6 cm
no I guess so
yeah I don't really see any big big play
that white hairs can't really can try to
sacrifice on g6 job Queen to g5 maybe
can be can be played now maybe just just
protect g6 he takes on f8 I take with
the king that's no big problem there
it's training Queens Wow check
yeah Jack an end game with a piece down
basically can take only three
intermediate move maybe check white
forfeits due to disconnection yeah no he
disconnected as I mentioned a number of
times the poor man's way of reasoning or
poor madness maybe the not really a nice
expression may be the very I don't know
a very simple minded were a person step
went to resign okay um what was somewhat
weird what's this setup here with with
92 a six also might surprise you but
this is in fact a valid line it's
normally doing like this so what black
is doing basically is only delaying the
c5 move form for oneness and he
anticipates this kind of situation where
very often White's bishop is coming to
be five and this is now with a six
prevented not that we should be five is
so terrible but a success some is a
valid line it's only a bit slow of
course like this c5 and now I would have
expected him to take on d5 on well c 3
is not bad it's not two not bad at all
he goes to an isolated queen point
position but here in 92 was a bit
strange why would you limit your Knights
activity you can now also just go here
and this now I can for example lead to
this position which is very comparable
to the game if we look at this yeah but
now it's neither is on e 2 and not on f3
+ f3 is the most much better much better
square maybe jump into e to g 5 to e5 at
some point and only towards them yeah
not doing very much oops wrong button
yeah and here I'm not sure there are
certainly many ways to play this in fact
I can even play night before here I
played 95 a bit too quickly this is a
pretty pretty decent alternative based
on the fact that we should be one is not
really great as it loses upon for no
compensation and this basically means
that Y chat has to take and now yeah
back to be one maybe okay okay at the
moment I'm not really threatening that
much maybe here this is not so great
because of rooks c4 and the Snider's in
danger of being trapped yeah it wasn't
alternative but 95 was fine I think yeah
Bishop b2 us again somewhat strange it
wasn't necessary yet to retreat but ok
will be six now just attacking the
weakness and I'm not sure how he defends
that maybe 95 maybe this is still
playable despite some stuff hanging here
maybe let's check check this funny
tactic but this seems good from black
and I can't even take him yeah I don't
know it does not look very promising but
this is just just really too simple I
just so gained the porn out for nothing
and here I'm just flat winning yeah
maybe I can just take here I wasn't I
wasn't so sure about this situation rook
the aid and then Queen h5 I don't know
and this irritated me bit by out of even
FG 6cm and I probably could have taken
only three with Queenie five is really
not much of a difference Black has an
extra porn he's got two bishops and he's
got the fantastic Queen only five which
is probably the most important thing it
cannot be driven away with the peace and
like it's just in kumon TM and okay this
gave away another piece you know in the
in the opening you really should play
Knight f3 going for an active piece
position in them in the IQ p alright
thanks for watching